Thanks so much for listening to Hidden Brain. Today we're presenting an encore of one of our favorite episodes Please enjoy it and come back next week for a brand new episode of Hidden Brain It was 2004 and Annie Duke was about to win two million dollars I'm all in and with that top-air Phil Helmuth going all in with his 450,000 chips, Annie Duke put the pressure on Phil when she checked, raised him. This was the final hand of the World Series of Poker tournament of champions. They had these incredible Hall of Fame players like Dwell Brunson who was a Hall of Famer, Johnny Chan who was a Hall of Famer, and then Phil Helmuth who has the most champion chips
非常感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。今天我们将为您重播我们最喜欢的节目之一。请好好欣赏，并期待下周收听《隐藏的大脑》的全新一期。那是2004年，安妮·杜克正准备赢得两00万美元。“我全押了。”随着顶级高手菲尔·赫尔穆特拿着45万筹码全押，安妮·杜克在过牌后加注，给菲尔施加了压力。这是世界扑克大赛冠军赛的最后一手牌。桌上有这些不可思议的名人堂玩家，比如身为名人堂成员的道尔·布朗森，身为名人堂成员的强尼·陈，还有拥有世界扑克大赛历史上
of anyone in the history of the World Series of Poker. And then there was me. And he calls the all-in. And Phil sees what he's up against. Annie and this guy Phil were the last two at the table. And Annie has overcome with emotion seeing how close she is to winning this championship. Annie's crying, Phil's standing up, piss pacing back and forth, the dealers laying out the cards that will determine who wins.
最多冠军筹码的菲尔·赫尔穆特。然后还有我。接着他跟注了全押。菲尔看到了他的对手。安妮和这个叫菲尔的家伙是桌上仅剩的两人。安妮看到自己离赢得这个冠军如此之近，情绪激动不已。安妮在哭泣，菲尔站着，来回踱步，荷官正在发牌，这张牌将决定谁能获胜。
Annie has control of his hand. Now here comes the turn. It's a seven. No help for Phil. Annie was the only woman in this competition. She had knocked out eight guys, eight of the best players in the world to get to this point. Annie, Duke, is now one card away from two million dollars?
安妮控制着这手牌。现在转牌来了。是一张七。对菲尔没有帮助。安妮是这场比赛中唯一的女性。她淘汰了八名男选手，八位世界上最好的玩家才走到了这一步。安妮·杜克，现在离两00万美元只有一张牌的距离了吗？
Um, but I didn't really feel like I deserve to be at that table. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today, we're going to take the whole podcast to tell you this story about being an outsider. It's why Annie Duke didn't feel she deserved to be at that table, and it's a perfect illustration of a very powerful idea and psychology called stereotype threat. It's an insidious thing, here's how it works. Let's say that you think people have a certain stereotype
嗯，但我其实并不觉得我配得上坐在那张桌子上。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天，我们要用整期播客来讲述这个关于身为局外人的故事。这就是为什么安妮·杜克觉得自己不配坐在那张桌子上，这也是对心理学中一个非常强大的概念——刻板印象威胁——的完美诠释。这是一件潜移默化的事，它是这样运作的。假设你认为人们对你有某种刻板印象，
about you. There's a part of you that's afraid that your actions and behavior will prove the stereotype true. I'm sort of thinking about, well, if I fold and I'm wrong, everybody's going to be like, see, she plays like a girl. Like, look how he pushed her around. But Annie's story is also about a second idea, and this idea often has a positive outcome. This idea is called stereotype tax.
你内心深处会害怕自己的行动和行为会证实这个刻板印象是真的。我当时在想，如果我弃牌而我猜错了，每个人都会觉得：“看吧，她打牌就像个女人。”就像，“看他是怎么把她逼入绝境的。”但安妮的故事也关乎第二个概念，而这个概念通常会产生积极的结果。这个概念被称为刻板印象税。
That's when a stereotype that others have about you works to your advantage. If somebody was at the table who was so emotionally invested in the fact that I was a woman, given that they're treating me that way, how can I come up with the best strategy to take their money? Because I guess in the end isn't that the best revenge. Annie had started playing poker in 1994. And by the time she got to that championship game ten years later, she had basically figured out how to make stereotypes about women and poker work for her. So, I can tell you that the first year that I played in the World Series
那是当别人对你的刻板印象对你有利的时候。如果桌上有人对我是个女人这件事有着强烈的感情投资，既然他们这样对待我，我该如何制定最佳策略来赢走他们的钱？因为我想最后这不就是最好的复仇吗。安妮在1994年开始打扑克。十年后，当她进入那场冠军赛时，她基本上已经弄清楚了如何让人们对女性和扑克的刻板印象为她所用。所以，我可以告诉你，我参加世界扑克大赛的头一年
poker main event, which was in 1994, 3% of the entrance were women, and last year that number would have been the same. Wow, so this is an extraordinarily male dominated sport. Completely. I was generally the only woman at the table. I had to really love that game in order to be willing to expose myself to a lot of the behavior that I was experiencing. Tell me what you heard. What did people say? There were people who were incredibly welcoming. There were other people, you know, there was one guy who I lost a pot to and he said,
主赛事是在1994年，3%的参赛者是女性，而去年这个数字也是一样的。哇，所以这是一项由男性主导得出奇的运动。完全是这样。我通常是桌上唯一的女性。我必须真正热爱这项游戏，才愿意让自己暴露在我所经历的许多行为中。告诉我你听到了什么。人们都说了什么？有些人非常热情。也有其他人，你知道的，有个家伙我输给他一把筹码，他说：
don't cry, I'll give you your money back if we go across the street to the northern. And the northern was a hotel. Wow. You know, and I got called a lot of bad things, but to think about it as, okay, given that this person is viewing me in a way that I find disrespectful, try to think about it as, okay, given that this person is viewing me in a way that I find disrespectful, try to separate yourself from your emotional reaction to that and think about how you can use that to your advantage. Annie had learned to make her opponents pay literally for the stereotypes they held
“别哭了，如果我们去街对面的北方酒店，我把钱还给你。”北方酒店是一家酒店。哇。你知道的，我挨了很多难听的话，但如果把这想成是：“好吧，既然这个人对我的看法我觉得是不尊重，”试着把你自己从对此的情绪反应中剥离出来，想想怎么能利用这一点为自己所用。安妮已经学会了让对手为他们对女性抱有的刻板印象付出代价，字面意义上的代价。
about women. Right. At the poker table, for example, I sort of in my head divided people into three categories. One was the flirting showvonist and that person was really viewing me in a way that was sexual. And not as overtly as the guy who invited her back to the great Northern Hotel. These were just guys who sometimes seem more concerned about getting Annie to like them, than they were about winning. Like, they'd show me their whole cards
没错。例如，在扑克桌上，我在脑海里把人分成三类。第一类是调情沙文主义者，这个人看待我的方式真的很色情。而且没有邀请她回大北方酒店的那个家伙那么露骨。这些只是有时看起来更关心如何让安妮喜欢他们，而不是赢得比赛的家伙。比如，当他们打完一手牌时，他们会把底牌亮给我看，
when they were done with the hand to show me whether it was a good fold or not. They'd kind of tell me during the hand, if I was alone with them, in the hand, you know, what they had. They were trying to make nice with you. They were trying to make nice with me. Exactly.
让我看看这手牌弃得好不好。如果我和他们单独在一起，在牌局进行中，他们会告诉我他们手里有什么牌。他们试图对你示好。他们试图对我示好。没错。
I never did go out on a date with any of them, but, you know, it was kind of flirtatious at the table, and I could use that to my advantage. Then there's a second kind of guy. What I would call the disrespecting show of anist, who mainly just thought that women weren't creative, that they could only think one level deep. So they didn't believe that you knew how to bluff, for example,
我从来没有和他们中的任何一个人约会过，但你知道的，桌上有点调情的意味，我可以利用这一点为我所用。然后是第二种类型的家伙。我称之为不尊重人的沙文主义者，他们主要认为女性没有创造力，她们只能深入思考一层。所以他们不相信你知道如何虚张声势，比如，
because that's a level deep in your thinking. They didn't think that you really had creativity. They thought you were very straightforward in the way that you played, because you know you're a girl. Right, so they assume that you're naive, basically. Exactly. So there are strategies that you can use against them. Mainly, you can bluff those people a lot.
因为那需要更深一层的思考。他们不认为你真的有创造力。他们认为你打牌的方式非常直白，因为你知道你是个女孩。没错，所以他们基本上认为你很天真。没错。所以你可以对付他们使用策略。主要是，你可以狠狠地诈唬这些人。
And then there's a third kind of guy, perhaps the most reckless. The angry showvonist. This is a guy who would do anything to avoid being beaten by a woman. You couldn't bluff them because they would call you all the time for fear that you might be bluffing them, and then they would also try to push you around a lot, so they would play extremely aggressively against you. They'd be trying to bluff you all the time, because the best thing that could happen to them was that they bluffed you, and then they could show you that they'd be trying to bluff you all the time. Because the best thing that could happen to them was that they bluffed you and then they could show you that they had a terrible
然后还有第三种类型的家伙，也许是最鲁莽的。愤怒的沙文主义者。这种人会不惜一切代价避免被一个女人击败。你无法诈唬他们，因为他们会一直跟你的注，生怕你是在诈唬他们，而且他们还会试图狠狠地把你逼入绝境，所以他们会对你采取极其激进的打法。他们会一直试图诈唬你，因为对他们来说最好的情况就是他们诈唬了你，然后他们可以向你展示——他们会一直试图诈唬你。因为对他们来说最好的情况就是他们诈唬了你，然后他们可以向你展示他们有一手烂牌，
hand and like be like, ha ha, little girl, look what happened to you. Right. Because that would confirm that everything that they believed about you was true. Right. So you can just sort of wait until they, what I say is until they would impale themselves on your chips. I have to ask you though, so it's clear that thinking about this mathematically and in a very detached and unemotional way gave you an edge at the poker table and I can clearly see how that's very smart. But you're not a robot, you're not a computer. At some level you also are processing how people actually are behaving toward you.
然后说：“哈哈，小女孩，看你落得什么下场。”没错。因为这会证实他们对你的一切看法都是真的。没错。所以你只需等待他们——我说的是直到他们把自己刺穿在你的筹码上。不过我得问你，显然，用数学的、非常超然且不带感情色彩的方式来思考，这在扑克桌上给了你优势，我完全能看出这有多聪明。但你不是机器人，你不是计算机。在某种程度上，你也在处理人们实际对待你的行为。
And I'm wondering if you could talk a minute about how this felt. Most of the time, I would compartmentalize while I was at the table. I would sort of say, I have emotions about this, I'm going to set them aside and deal with them later. And then I would leave the table and drive home in tears. Coming up, feeling like an imposter. It was always in the back of my mind, like, do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me?
我想知道你能否花一分钟谈谈这感觉如何。大多数时候，我在桌上时都会进行心理隔离。我会对自己说：“对此我会有情绪，我要把它们放在一边，以后再处理。”然后我会离开牌桌，一路哭着开车回家。接下来，感觉自己像个骗子。这总是在我的脑海深处盘旋，比如：“他们真的尊重我吗？他们为什么跟我说话？”
Is it just because I'm a girl or do they actually respect my play? More from Annie Duke, after this. Welcome back to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam. We're talking with poker champion Annie Duke about stereotypes, how they affected her and how she learned to turn them to her own advantage. In her first 10 years of the poker table, Annie was able to compartmentalize her emotions, and she won a lot of money doing this, using stereotype tax to her advantage.
是因为我是个女孩，还是他们真的尊重我的牌技？稍后为您带来更多安妮·杜克的访谈。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们正在与扑克冠军安妮·杜克谈论刻板印象、它们如何影响她以及她如何学会将它们转化为自己的优势。在扑克桌上的前十年里，安妮能够将自己的情绪进行心理隔离，她通过这种方式赢得了许多钱，利用刻板印象税为自己谋利。
That was until 2004 at the Tournament of Champions. Intimidation is such a big part of being a successful player. Is that going to come into play at this table, you think? Oh, not really. In fact, these players know each other so well. If one of them sneezes, somebody else has already handed them a handkerchief. Actually, at least for Annie, that wasn't true. She had never played poker on TV before, and she was pretty sure she had been invited as the token woman, that she was way out of her league. She thought that ESPN, televising the game in this way for the first time,
直到2004年的冠军赛。恐吓是成为一名成功玩家的重要组成部分。你觉得这会在桌上发挥作用吗？哦，不会真的。事实上，这些玩家彼此太熟悉了。如果其中一个人打喷嚏，另一个人已经递上手帕了。事实上，至少对安妮来说，并非如此。她以前从未在电视上打过扑克，她确信自己被邀请只是作为一个象征性的女性，她觉得自己远远不够级别。她认为ESPN首次以这种方式转播比赛，
just thought it was good optics to have her there. And I went in there with this incredible fear that my play, which was now in front of lipstick cameras, so my mistakes were no longer gonna be private to me. That was gonna expose that everybody was right, and I was actually a terrible player, and despite the fact that I had spent the last 10 years making my living playing poker at the highest levels of the game,
只是觉得有她在场面会很好看。我带着巨大的恐惧走进去，因为我的牌技现在暴露在口红摄像机前，所以我的错误不再属于我个人。这会暴露所有人都是对的，我其实是个糟糕的玩家，尽管过去十年我一直在最高水平的扑克比赛中谋生，
that I didn't really deserve to have ever won anything I was bad and I had just gotten lucky and now everybody was gonna know it and what they were saying was true. You felt like an imposter. Completely. You were facing a very difficult situation here, which is you're not just juggling with what's happening at the poker table, but you're juggling with all of this other psychological crap in a way that
我其实根本不配赢得任何东西，我很糟糕，我只是运气好，现在每个人都会知道了，他们说的是真的。你觉得自己像个骗子。完全是这样。你当时面对着一个非常困难的局面，那就是你不仅要应付扑克桌上发生的事情，还要应付所有这些其他的心理垃圾，
just makes it hard to focus on what it is that you're actually doing. And in so many ways, that not to me is a perfect illustration of stereotype threat. It shows that when there's a stereotype that's in the air, when there's a stereotype that multiple people believe, even if you don't believe it yourself, if you're the person who is potentially at the receiving end of that stereotype, it affects your behavior in such a way that you become more likely to make the stereotype come true. I think that that's completely true. It was always in the back of my mind, like, do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me? Is it just because they are thinking about me in a different way? Like, they want to be friends with me because I'm a girl,
这让你很难专注于你实际上在做的事情。在很多方面，对我来说，这完美诠释了刻板印象威胁。它表明，当空中弥漫着一种刻板印象，当多人相信某种刻板印象时，即使你自己不相信，如果你是那个可能成为该刻板印象接收端的人，它就会以这样一种方式影响你的行为：你变得更有可能让这个刻板印象成真。我认为这是完全正确的。它总是在我的脑海深处盘旋，比如：“他们真的尊重我吗？他们为什么跟我说话？”是因为他们对我的看法不同吗？比如，他们想和我交朋友因为我是个女孩，
or do they actually respect my play? There was a particular hand, Annie says, when stereotype threat got the better of her. So in this particular hand where I had two tens. This was early in the game. There were nine people still at the table. And for Annie. Certainly in the beginning of that tournament, I just kept thinking to myself like, oh, please don't let me be the first one out, because then everybody will be right.
还是他们真的尊重我的牌技？安妮说，有一手特定的牌，当时刻板印象威胁占了上风。所以在那手特定的牌里，我手里有一对十。这盘棋还很早。桌上还有九个人。对于安妮来说。当然是在锦标赛刚开始的时候，我一直对自己说：“哦，拜托，别让我第一个被淘汰，因为那样的话每个人就都对了。”
Because of course, she wasn't good enough, she didn't belong at the table, she couldn't hang with the guys. That discourse was kind of running in the back of my head the whole time. And then Annie winds up in a head-to-head match-up with one other player. Her hand was a pair of tens, which is a pretty good hand. It was good enough that there wasn't a huge chance that her opponent, this guy Greg Raymer, had a better hand, but there was still a chance. As a professional poker player, this is the kind of hand that you evaluate
因为当然了，她不够优秀，她不属于这张桌子，她无法跟男人们抗衡。这种言论一直在我的脑海深处盘旋。然后安妮最终与另一位玩家进行了一对一的对决。她的手牌是一对十，这是一手相当不错的牌。这手牌足够好，她的对手——这个叫格雷格·雷默的家伙——手牌更好的几率并不大，但仍然存在这种可能。作为一名职业扑克玩家，这是那种你可以在几秒钟内
in a matter of seconds. So I really needed to eliminate that hand as a possibility and I was having a lot of trouble doing that because I was so afraid of making this really bad big decision on television and and having everyone say I told you so. This was a pivotal hand, but a lot of the significance was really just in Annie's head. If she folded but really had the best hand, everybody's gonna be like see she plays like a girl like look how he pushed her around. And if I called and I was wrong, plays like a girl, like look how he pushed her around. And if I called and I was wrong,
评估完的手牌。所以我真的需要排除那手牌的可能性，但我很难做到这一点，因为我太害怕在电视上做出这个非常糟糕的重大决定，然后让每个人都说“我早就告诉你了”。这是一手关键牌，但其中的很大一部分意义其实只存在于安妮的脑海里。如果我弃牌但实际上我拿了最好的牌，每个人都会觉得：“看吧，她打牌就像个女人，看他是怎么把她逼入绝境的。”如果我跟注而我猜错了，打牌就像个女人，看他是怎么把她逼入绝境的。如果我跟注而我猜错了，
then I could come up with a whole other thing. Like look how bad she could, didn't she know that he had the best hand, like any idiot would have known that, you know. And that was running in my head as I was trying to make this decision. So you're down to if you do and you're down to if you don't? Absolutely, absolutely.
那我就会想出另一套说辞。比如：“看她有多蠢，难道她不知道他拿了最好的牌吗？任何白痴都看得出来。”当我试图做出这个决定时，这些想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋。所以横竖都是死？完全是，完全是。
And it was incredibly difficult. And it wasn't until I kind of snapped to and saw this tell that he had. And we see a tell, you mean what? So a tell is a physical, well, it could be something verbal that somebody says that gives a clue. But generally, when we talk about tells, we're talking about something physical that somebody does,
这简直难如登天。直到我突然清醒过来，看到了他身上的一个小动作。当我们说小动作时，你指的是什么？所以小动作是一个身体上的，嗯，也可以是某人说的提供线索的话语。但通常情况下，当我们谈论小动作时，我们指的是某人做的某个身体动作，
that telegraphs the quality of their hand, or at least what they think the quality of their hand is. So Greg Raymer did something which I haven't actually said what he actually did, because I think that's unfair to him. But he did something that gave away the fact that his hand was very, very strong, which allowed me to then fold.
它能透露出他们手牌的质量，或者至少是他们认为自己手牌质量如何。所以格雷格·雷默做了一件事——我其实没有说他具体做了什么，因为我觉得这对不公平。但他做了一件事，泄露了他的手牌非常非常强这一事实，这让我得以弃牌。
And at that moment, I was actually quite confident in it. But Annie's confidence in her decision was short-lived. Another player came up to her during a break in the game and what he said, kicked the stereotype threat in Annie's head into overdrive. Phil Helmuth, right after that hand occurred, came up and just told me like, what an idiot I was because clearly Greg Raymer had Ace King. And I thought, oh my gosh, this is a guy who's like, at the now, I think he's a 12-time world champion.
在那一刻，我其实对此相当自信。但安妮对这个决定的自信并没有持续多久。另一位玩家在比赛中场休息时找到了她，他所说的话让安妮脑海中的刻板印象威胁瞬间爆棚。菲尔·赫尔穆特在那手牌刚打完后就走过来，告诉我我有多蠢，因为格雷格·雷默明显拿着A和K。我想，哦天哪，这家伙——现在我想他是12次世界冠军了。
But at the time, he probably had, you know, seven world championships or something. And he seemed pretty confident that he had Ace King. And oh, no, and it was just, and then I had an hour in my room having a panic attack. Well, we were on break from the tournament. It was pretty awful. Annie's stereotype threat had produced what poker players
但当时，他可能已经有了，你知道的，七次世界冠军头衔左右。而且他似乎非常确信自己拿的是A和K。哦不，这简直，然后我在房间里恐慌发作了一个小时。当时我们正在锦标赛的中场休息。这太糟糕了。安妮的刻板印象威胁引发了扑克玩家
call tilt. Tilt. When you allow kind of bad things that happen to you that very often are out of your control to cause you to be a poor decision maker going forward. You know, Annie, social science researchers have figured out one way to beat stereotype threat. There was an interesting experiment conducted at Stanford University by Greg Walton and others
所说的“情绪失控”（tilt）。情绪失控。当你允许发生在自己身上、通常是你无法控制的糟糕事情，导致你在接下来的行动中成为一个糟糕的决策者时。你知道吗，安妮，社会科学研究人员已经找到了克服刻板印象威胁的一种方法。斯坦福大学的格雷格·沃顿等人做过一个有趣的实验，
where he was concerned that black students at Stanford might feel that they were imposterous on campus and when negative things happen to them they get a bad grade or a bad interaction with a professor. They'll interpret that in the light of thinking, I don't really belong here. And so he had the students come in and he had them describe negative things that happened to them during their freshman year, but he also had them describe how those negative things were transient events. You get a bad grade or you have a bad interaction, but two weeks later, that's not a big deal anymore.
他当时担心斯坦福大学的黑人学生可能会觉得自己是校园里的冒名顶替者，当负面事情发生在他们身上时——他们得了低分或者与教授发生了不愉快的互动——他们会把这解释为“我真的不属于这里”。于是他让学生们进来，让他们描述大一期间发生的负面事情，但他也让他们描述这些负面事情是如何转瞬即逝的事件。你得了一个低分或者有了一次不愉快的互动，但两周后，那就不算什么大不了的事了。
Right. And he was using this as a way to get students to understand that everyone experiences setbacks. It's only when you see local setbacks as global problems that the risk of stereotype threat comes in and you start to feel like an imposter. Exactly. And it's something that I've used a lot at the table.
没错。他用这种方法让学生们明白，每个人都会经历挫折。只有当你把局部的挫折视为全局性的问题时，刻板印象威胁的风险才会介入，你才会开始觉得自己像个冒名顶替者。完全正确。这也是我在牌桌上经常使用的方法。
When I lose a big pot and it feels like the end of the world, I try to think about how will that really affect my bottom line in the long run. So an example would be you get a flat tire, you're standing by the side of the road, it feels like the worst thing that's ever happened to you. And then if you stop for a second and you say to yourself, well, if it's a year from now, will that flat tire have affected my happiness for the year in any way? And the answer to that, of course, is no. It wouldn't tick it up or down.
当我输掉一大盘筹码觉得天都要塌下来时，我会试着思考，这从长远来看究竟会如何影响我的净收益。举个例子，比如你轮胎瘪了，站在路边，这感觉就像你经历过的最糟糕的事情。然后如果你停下来一秒钟对自己说：“好吧，如果是一年以后，那个瘪了的轮胎会以任何方式影响我这一年的幸福感吗？”答案当然是没有。它不会让你的幸福感上升或下降。
So in that same sense, when you have something really bad happen to stop for a second thing about, well, I've had stuff like this happen to me before, when it was a few weeks later, did it really affect my overall level of happiness? And the answer is generally no. And just a moment, the conclusion of the poker championship. Annie Duke is now one card away from $2 million.
所以在同样的意义上，当发生非常糟糕的事情时，停下来一秒钟想想：“好吧，以前我也经历过类似的事情，几周后，它真的影响了我的整体幸福水平吗？”答案通常是没有。稍后为您带来扑克锦标赛的尾声。安妮·杜克现在距离两00万美元只有一张牌的距离。
You won't want to miss this. Phil Helm you'll see that eight to win this pot. Both players on their feet. We'd like to say a quick thank you to one of our sponsors, stamps.com. Stamps.com helps businesses avoid time consuming trips to the post office. Use your own computer and printer to print official US postage for any letter or package. Then the mailman picks it up. No more wasting time going to the post office or wasting money on expensive postage meters. Right now, sign up for Stamps.com and use the promo code Brain for a special offer. A four-week trial, plus postage, and a digital scale. Go to Stamps.com, click on the microphone,
你绝对不想错过这个。菲尔·赫尔穆特需要一张八来赢得这局牌。两位选手都站了起来。我们要向我们的赞助商之一Stamps.com表达简短的谢意。Stamps.com帮助企业免去前往邮局的耗时行程。使用您自己的电脑和打印机即可为任何信件或包裹打印官方美国邮资。然后邮递员会来取件。再也不会浪费时间去邮局，也不会在昂贵的邮资机上浪费金钱了。现在，注册Stamps.com并使用优惠码Brain即可享受特别优惠。四周免费试用，外加邮资和数字秤。访问Stamps.com，点击麦克风，
and type in Brain. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. Every week, NPR's pop culture happy hour brings you a fun and funny conversation about the best in movies, TV shows, books, music, and more. From Train Rec to KeyNPL to movie soundtracks to the latest Judy Bloom book, you'll bound to hear something that makes you happy every week. That's Pop Culture Happy Hour from NPR. Find it now at npr.org slash podcast and on the NPR1 app. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I'm talking with Annie Duke about the final
并输入Brain。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。每周，NPR的流行文化欢乐时光为您带来关于电影、电视节目、书籍、音乐等最佳内容的有趣且滑稽的对话。从火车大劫案到黑人兄弟，再到电影原声带，再到最新的朱迪·布鲁姆小说，你每周一定会听到让你开心的内容。这就是NPR的流行文化欢乐时光。现在可以在npr.org斜杠podcast以及NPR1应用程序上找到它。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我正在与扑克冠军安妮·杜克讨论世界最大扑克锦标赛的最后几手牌。
hands in the world's biggest poker champion. So after she nearly lost it in her hotel room, Annie comes back to the table and she has a stroke of luck. She wins a pretty nice hand. And the river card, it's a six of spades, no help for Greg Ramer. He loses that hand. Annie Duke lives to tell the tale yet again, doubles her mind. And you can actually hear at this point in the game, Annie begins to lose an up. It's a sign that she's finally gotten the stereotype threat under control. The flop was just wow.
所以在酒店房间里险些崩溃之后，安妮回到了牌桌上，她迎来了一点好运。她赢了一手相当不错的牌。河牌是一张黑桃六，对格雷格·雷默毫无帮助。他输掉了那手牌。安妮·杜克再次死里逃生，筹码翻倍。你其实可以听到，此时在比赛中，安妮开始松了一口气。这表明她终于控制住了刻板印象威胁。翻牌圈简直太棒了。
Yeah, it doesn't matter what order they come in, right? It doesn't matter, well, it kind of does in that situation. Annie had turned on the charm with Greg Raymer. And the next time they face each other in a hand, Raymer got cocky. Now Raymer needs to call or get out of the way. I don't know what he's thinking about here. It's one thing when he called with 9-8 suited before,
是的，它们以什么顺序出现并不重要，对吧？其实并无所谓，嗯，在这种情况下确实有那么一点。安妮对格雷格·雷默使出了魅力攻势。下一次他们在牌局中相遇时，雷默变得狂妄自大。现在雷默需要跟注或者退场。我不知道他在想什么。当他之前拿着同花9和8跟注时是一回事，
when he was chip leader and was a small cost. But he has a lot fewer chips and not as good of a hand. I call. Well the world champion is gonna call. Just to be clear, this was not the right thing to do. Raymer had a pretty weak hand. And now the river card, it's a three no good for Raymer. Well calling that all in with the 98 off suit line, that's a meltdown of sorts for Greg Ramer.
当时他是筹码领先者，代价很小。但他现在的筹码少得多，手牌也没那么好。我跟注。好吧，世界冠军要跟注了。坦白说，这不是正确的做法。雷默的牌相当弱。现在河牌是一张三，对雷默毫无用处。用杂色9和8跟注全押，对格雷格·雷默来说这某种程度上可以说是崩盘了。
On the next hand, Annie would knock out Ramer, whose nickname was Fossilman. It is an A-sits, no help to Fossilman and he goes down. He played really well. Just like that, Annie was back in the zone. And that actually sort of brought me out of this very bad headspace. Soon, the table dwindled to four players. Helmuth knocking out Johnny Chan in fourth place. Then there were three.
在下一手牌中，安妮将淘汰绰号为“化石人”的雷默。这是一张A和6，对化石人毫无帮助，他出局了。他打得非常好。就这样，安妮重新找到了状态。这实际上把我从那种非常糟糕的心态中拉了出来。很快，桌上的人数缩减到四人。赫尔穆特淘汰了获得第四名的强尼·陈。接着剩下三人。
It's a three and that's the end of the line for Howard Letterman. Until finally, Annie and Phil Helmuth, the guy who nearly destroyed her confidence earlier in the game, these are the only two left. And Annie says to him, this is all right, you know. I'm just happy to be in the final two. I mean, seriously, I don't my money off in the first two hours. You could argue that this little old me act
是一张三，霍华德·莱德曼的征程到此结束。直到最后，安妮和菲尔·赫尔穆特——那个早些时候差点摧毁她自信心的家伙——场上只剩下他们两个人。安妮对他说：“这挺好的，你知道的。我很高兴能进入前两名。我是说，说真的，我没有在前两小时就把钱输光。”你可以说这个“小女子”把戏
somehow really did a number on Phil Helmut. Because for the next half a dozen hands, he just did not know what to make of Annie. Well, Annie Duke will shy away from this hand. God dang it all, I should have moved in before the fall. Annie keeps the charm turned up. Are you saying you had a good hand, Phil? I had a pocket pair.
不知怎么地真的把菲尔·赫尔穆特给弄懵了。因为在接下来的半打牌里，他根本不知道该拿安妮怎么办。好吧，安妮·杜克将在这手牌中退缩。真他妈的，我早该在翻牌前就全押的。安妮继续保持着她的魅力攻势。你是说你有一手好牌吗，菲尔？我有一对口袋牌。
Sorry, I couldn't accommodate you. You gave me the raise. Yeah. And they go back and forth like this all the way to the final hand. Annie's got Phil second-gassing every movie makes, and every movie doesn't make. And they go back and forth like this all the way to the final hand. Phil Helmuth was holding a 10-8. But Annie's hand was much better, a King 10. Annie Duke is going to raise Phil Hel000 as she has set her trap.
对不起，我没能配合你。你加注了。是的。他们就这样你来我往，一直打到最后一手牌。安妮让菲尔对他的每一个动作以及没有做的每一个动作都产生二次猜测。他们就这样你来我往，一直打到最后一手牌。菲尔·赫尔穆特拿着一张10和8。但安妮的牌要好得多，是一张K和10。安妮·杜克要对菲尔·赫尔穆特加注，因为她已经设好了陷阱。
Phil thought Annie was bluffing. In fact, he thought that she'd been bluffing a lot. I'm all in. And with that top pair, Phil, Helmuth going all in with his 450,000 chips, Annie duke put the pressure on Phil when she checked, raised him. And now, what Phil's all in call, the pressure is back on Annie. About 450 more. She set the trap, call the pressure is back on Annie. About 450 more. She set the trap but Phil has come back very strong.
菲尔以为安妮在虚张声势。事实上，他认为她一直在虚张声势。我全押了。随着顶级对子菲尔·赫尔穆特拿着他的45万筹码全押，安妮·杜克在过牌加注后给菲尔施加了压力。现在，随着菲尔的跟注全押，压力回到了安妮这边。大约还要加45万。她设下了陷阱，但菲尔的反扑非常强劲。
At this point, it's obvious to both Annie and Phil the other person has a strong hand. The question is how strong? That's a judgement call. It's based on probability, instinct, and all the undecorrents, expectations, and stereotypes that have been running through the game the entire time. But now there's only one question. If Annie thinks that Phil has misjudged her, she knows she should call his bet. I call.
此时，安妮和菲尔都很清楚对方有一手好牌。问题是多好？这是一个主观判断。它基于概率、直觉，以及贯穿整场比赛的所有潜流、期望和刻板印象。但现在只有一个问题。如果安妮认为菲尔对她做出了错误判断，她就知道自己应该跟注他的下注。我跟注。
Annie calls the all in! And Phil sees what he's up against. What he's up against, you're meaning the dealer's cards. That's going to determine who wins. And if there was any moment that perfectly revealed how much of an outsider Annie was in this situation, it's this next one. Annie Dukes now won card away from $2 million. In 8, please.
安妮跟注了全押！菲尔看到了他的对手。他面对的对手，指的是荷官的牌。那将决定谁能获胜。如果说有哪个瞬间完美展现了安妮在这种情况下是多么像一个局外人，那就是接下来这个瞬间。安妮·杜克现在距离两00万美元只有一张牌的距离。来张八吧。
Phil Helmuth needs an eight to win this pot. Both players on their feet, anticipating the river card. It's a three. Any Duke has defeated nine of the strongest poker players in the world. Oh, ****. And when's the first ever World Series a poker tournament of champion?
菲尔·赫尔穆特需要一张八来赢得这局牌。两位选手都站了起来，期待着河牌的出现。是一张三。安妮·杜克击败了世界上九位最强的扑克玩家。哦，操。并且赢得了历史上第一届世界扑克大赛冠军赛！
She won every **** race for two **** days. In classic reality television style, cameras fall of fail as he storms away from the table, out of door just pacing around talking to himself. She check-raise me six times. I know she didn't have it all six times. Oh my god, I won! It was the reaction of a man who just got beat.
她连续两天赢得了每一场他妈的比赛。在经典的真人秀电视风格中，摄像机跟着愤怒离开牌桌的菲尔，他摔门而出，在外面走廊里踱步自言自语。“她过牌加注了我六次。我知道她不可能六次都有牌。”哦天哪，我赢了！这是一个刚刚被打败的男人的反应。
She had to be 30 to 1 to win this. By some one, I love Annie, who wasn't supposed to win. But, fuck. And maybe wasn't even supposed to be at the table in the first place. What the fuck? What's going on? But precisely because Annie Duke knew how stereotypes can
她夺冠的赔率一定是三十分之一。客观来说，我爱安妮，她本不该赢的。但是，操。也许她一开始根本就不应该坐在那张桌子上。他妈的怎么回事？怎么回事？但正因为安妮·杜克深知刻板印象既可以成为威胁也可以成为优势，所以——
be both threat and advantage, well. Well, you heard Phil, and he was right. Annie was definitely a long shot to win this all But as the only female at the table she is now the last man standing Another second from my second third second third. I have to say I need you You're not just a good poker player, but you're clearly a very wise person Well, so are you thank you. Thank you so much for talking with us today, Annie. I really, really appreciate it. Thank you for having me. It was a lot of fun. I see it, but I don't leave it. I just don't believe it.
好吧，你听到菲尔的话了，他说得对。安妮这次获胜的几率绝对很低。但作为桌上唯一的女性，她现在是笑到最后的胜者。“再给我一秒钟，我的第二、第三、第三……”我得说，安妮·杜克，你不仅是个出色的扑克玩家，而且显然是个非常聪明的人。好吧，你也是，谢谢。非常感谢今天能和我们交谈，安妮。我真的很感激。谢谢邀请我。这非常有趣。我看到了，但我不敢相信。我就是不敢相信。
For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook and Twitter. You can also listen to me on your local public radio station. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agk-Allison and Maggie Penman. Special thanks this week to Brent Bachman and Jenna Weissberman. I knew I was going to eventually get a hell of a kid genius event. No money. All right, let me call my brother. She wants two million. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR.
想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在脸书和推特上关注我们。你也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。本期《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿格克-艾森和玛吉·彭曼制作。本周特别鸣谢布伦特·巴赫曼和珍娜·维斯曼。我知道我最终会遇到一个天才少年的节目。没钱。好吧，让我给我兄弟打个电话。她想要两00万。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
I see it, but I don't believe it. I just don't believe it. I just can't believe it. brother Howard to call. I see it, but I don't believe it. I just don't believe it. I just can't believe it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我看到了，但我不敢相信。我就是不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。给哥哥霍华德打电话。我看到了，但我不敢相信。我就是不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。